باستدعاء رئيس البعثة
الدبلوماسية الفلسطينية في
المانيا احتجاجا على كلمة الفصل
العنصري. القوات التركية تدفع
بتعزيزات اضافية الى شمال سوريا
تجدد الاشتباكات مع قسد. هكذا
فهل يصبح اعداء الامس اصدقاء
اليوم بعد احدى عشر عاما على
ان وايسلبر بيرج اقر بالذنب ازاء
خمس عشرة تهمة تتعلق بالاختلاس
مقتل العقيد القذافي والقبض على
ابنه سيف الاسلام قال قائد عملية
الولايات المتحدة وحلف الناتو
يفهمان الوضع بحديثهما عن
ببشار الاسد مع التأكيد بان
انقرة لا تطمع باي اراض سوري.
زابروتش النووي برأيكم? الاحداث
والتطورات الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
وهما في حالة الرد وفي حالة
الظروف الطارئة او التهديد
سيستطيع حفيد عثمان اقناع بوتين
بشروط زلنسكي? دخان الموت يقترب.
محذرا روسيا من فصل محطة
زابوروتشيا عن شبكة الكهرباء
جوتيريش لاتهامنا. نحن الان نوثق
ذلك بالاقمار الاصطناعية لادانة
حال انسحابها من الاراضي التي
تسيطر عليها بشكل غير مشروع في
الشمالية المقايضة بكرامتها
بينما حفيد عثمان قد يشد رحاله
وصغيرة. الهدف من صغر حجمها هو
تقليص المسافات ليقترب الحل. ما
لانقاذ العالم من حرب عالمية قد
تصل نارها اليه فقد نسق في مدينة
بعد ان انقذ حفيد عثمان الغذاء
العالمي ها هو اليوم يتطلع
ترامب النفايس البرج بالذنب بتهم
تتعلق بالتحايل الضريبي خلال
الفين وثمانية عشر لربط روسيا
بشبه جزيرة القرم عن جسر القرم
اردوغان لا يلمح الى اعادة
العلاقات مع النظام السوري ممثلا
الى دخان الموت. حيث رفضت روسيا
مقترحا اوكرانيا يحث على نزع
الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شويجو قائلا
لا نحتاج الى استخدام اسلحة
المتحدة طرفا في الصراع مع
اوكرانيا واشار الى ان واشنطن لم
الشمالية. بل تذهب يا رجل. لا
يوجد للكرامة قطع غيار. لقد تم
التحدث بالهراء اليس لديه شيء
افضل ليقول وتقصد هنا رئيس كوريا
لا تلعب. للجنون فنون. حرب
كلامية وتصريحات نارية انطلقت
امريكي على الصين بعد ارسالها
قوة ضخمة لروسيا? كوريا الشمالية
مبادرة الحوار الوطني وتخوفات
كبيرة من عواقب ذلك. وبين
اما في العراق ما يزال التيار
الصدري يبدي رفضا واضحا لمقترحات
اوكرانيا **** قائلا يدهشني ان
اسمع من الرئيس اردوغان ان روسيا
كاليفورنيا. ويأتي هذا وسط تفاقم
التوتر بين واشنطن وروسيا والصين
تسعى للسلام. ليصرح الجانب
الروسي قائلا لقد حصلنا على
الى روسيا الهدف منها اطفاء
النار المشتعلة. برأيكم هل
وتزوير السجلات التجارية. وصف
الالماني تصريح الرئيس الفلسطيني
احرج الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي مترجمه
وصحح له المعلومات على العلن
اسرائيل ارتكبت خمسين مجزرة مما
اثار غضب الالمان لترد برلين
سيف هو اطلاق النار على رأسه.
اقر المدير المالي السابق لمنظمة
اليهودية في روسيا وذلك بناء على
دعوى قضائية تقدمت بها وزارة
يضرب القاضي لتعلن المحكمة
الجزائية حكمها باغلاق الوكالة
الوجودي. هذا ما صرح به وزير
الخارجية الروسي. ليؤكد ذلك وزير
تحت التهديد. اوكرانيا تهدد بقطع
شريان روسيا الحيوي بتدمير جسر
تستمع جيدا تحذيرات موسكو من
الانخراط في الصراع موضحة ان
وبحثت القمة تطورات الحرب في
اوكرانيا ليشد زينيسكي طاولة
ولكن الرد كان ابلغ. تركيا تطفئ
نار اوكرانيا. في طاولة مستديرة
نظرية النفط مقابل الحماية.
والامر يتكرر مع كوريا الشمالية
تطبيق هذه النظرية مع العرب وهي
نظرية النفط مقابل الغذاء وكذلك
لتعلق روسيا سنلجأ لاستخدام
سلاحنا النووي في حالتين فقط
الولايات المتحدة تجري تجاربها
الصاروخية الدفاعية النووية
نادي كمال الاجسام النووية
لاستعراض العضلات العسكرية. هنا
معلومات استخباراتية تشير الى ان
كييف ستقصف زابروتش اثناء جولة
الجنوبية للشمالية بشرط التخلي
عن الترسانة النووية لتضيف كيم
البيبي الاوكرانية اجتماعا
ثلاثيا بين الاوكراني زيننسكي
والتركي اردوجان والامين العام
للامم المتحدة انطونيو جوتيريس.
يوم على توليه المنصب. مشددا على
نزع السلاح النووي من كوريا
كييب. وقد رصدنا قوات مجتمعة في
عدة مناطق زابروتشيا. ليصرح
استعراض العضلات النووية بين
الدول الكبرى ترفض كوريا
يصدم العالم العربي بهذا التصريح
والصدر يرد على الحكومة العراقية
النووية لاكثر من اربع مرات
بحلول عام الفين وثلاث وهنا
ليقع ترامب في مصيدة القضاء
الامريكي. سيف الاسلام القذافي
والامين العام للامم المتحدة
انطونيو جوتيريش.
خلال القمة الثلاثية التي جمعته
مع الرئيس التركي اردوغان
اقترح تقديم الدعم الاقتصادي
كوريا الشمالية وذلك بمناسبة مئة
عديمة الاحترام وغير لائقة. يون
رئيس كوريا الجنوبية. كان قد
عليها بالجبهة. لترد كوريا
الجنوبية ان تصريحات كيميو جونج
محمود عباس بالفاضح وذلك في
مؤتمر صحفي قال فيه عباس ان
القبض على سيف الاسلام العقيد
العجمي العتيري ان كل ما طلبه
عمله في المنظمات طوال خمسة عشر
عاما. وذكرت وسائل اعلام امريكية
بانه ليس لديه اي اسلحة ثقيلة في
محطة زابروتش. فكيف سينتهي مسلسل
شرارتها من كوريا الشمالية تضع
شقيقة الزعيم الكوري يدها على
التي يعود تاريخها الى
التسعينات. فهل هذا برأيكم رد
تطورا وهي نسخة مطورة واكثر
تعقيدا من مقاتلات اذ ستة عشر
عثمان? اسرائيل تقع في ورطة مع
الصين. وامريكا تستعرض بسلاح
نووي جديد وروسيا ترد. واوكرانيا
تهدد بقطع شريان روسيا الحيوية
وهي طائرة حربية امريكية الصنع
من طراز اف ستة عشر بي الاكثر
يحاول ان يشتري شرف كوريا
الشمالية بالاموال والغذاء.
زنادها السياسي وتصرح كان من
الافضل له ان يغلق دمه بدلا من
السلاح من محيط محطة زابروتش
النووية. حيث برر الجيش الروسي
وقالت لا نقيض مصيرنا وكرامتنا
بكعكة ذرة. بوم هادي اللي يقولوا
كرش الذي شيدته موسكو بتكلفة
عالية وافتتحه الرئيس الروسي عام
احتمالية وقوع هجوم على الاراضي
الروسية من اوكرانيا هنا بوتين
نووية في اوكرانيا. واضاف ان
روسيا لا تريد ان تصبح الولايات
الصين توجه رسالة تحذيرية وشديدة
اللهجة الى اسرائيل حذرت خلالها
الاوكرانية ليشد بعدها اردوجان
رحاله ويحدد وجهته لزيارة محتملة
الحوار اليه حول ما اسماه
الابتزاز النووي الروسي في
الاعتراضية والتي كان اخرها على
صاروخ مينتمان انطلاقا من سواحل
فلسطينية على اساس الاتفاقات
الدولية وتناصر الفلسطينيين
والدولية في واشنطن فان الصين
تعمل بجد لتضاعف حجم ترسانتها
العالم فقط بل باتت تمتلك قوة
عسكرية ضخمة لا يستهان بها تلوح
زبروتشا ويضع شرطه النهائي ان
الحوار مع روسيا ممكن وذلك في
وبالاخص المطبعين منهم. الرد جاء
من الحليفة موسكو بانتظار ان
كبار في وزارة الخارجية
الاسرائيلية شهدت العلاقات بين
العدل الروسية. ترسل هنا امريكا
هدية لتايوان من اجل اغاظة الصين
الجنوبية وذلك ردا على ارض
المساعدة التي تقدمت بها الجارة
يو جونغ. يون ساذج ولا يزال
صبيانيا معتبرة تصريح هذا انه
اسرائيل. لم تتوقف الصين عند
تطوير نفوذها الاقتصادي في
يصل الى حل لانهاء الحرب
الاوكرانية. فما هو الحل يا حفيد
نحن لا نقيد مصيرنا وكرامتنا
بقطعة خبز. كما فعلت امريكا مع
فبماذا سترد موسكو? ومستشار
ترامب يعترف ويقر بهذا الذنب
البلدين خلافات في الماضي بشأن
القضية فالصين تعترف بدولة
بالعلاقات مع السلطات في بكين
وذلك بحسب موقع ووفقا لمسؤولين
باستمرار في الامم المتحدة وهذا
ما يزعج الاسرائيليين من الصين.
هنا نقف قليلا لقراءة صورة
الفاتحة على رح النخوة العربية
تل ابيب من الرضوخ لما اسمته
بالضغوط الامريكية والاضرار
بعصاها لترد على اي تهديد. ووفق
مركز الدراسات الاستراتيجية
فيما الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود
عباس يغضب الالمان. الصين تهدد
بعض الدول. هكذا قالتا شقيقة
الزعيم الكوري. والرئيس التركي
الى بوتين فهل سيعود مع سلام
دولي ام سيعود خائبا بخفي حنين.